there's no
uh better gifts in this world than a
book about hitler so thank you so much
i i've gotten a gift when i was were
just talking yes blind right the watch
from joe rogan
and this almost beats it so uh
so tell me what uh this particular book
on hitler is so this is volume two
yes so this is ian kershaw he wrote the
famous
two volume on hitler i'm a big book nerd
and i spend a lot of time reading
biographies
in particular so this one um if you need
a one volume
rise and fall the third reich right i
think you talked about that william
shire because that's like
hitler's rise nazi germany the war etc
but i like
bios because it's the good biography is
story of the times
right and so this one the first volume
it does exactly that which is that
it doesn't just tell the story of hitler
it's the context of poor you know this
kid in austria and he's got all these
dreams but then
actually pretty courageous in terms of
world war one right gets pinned to metal
on by the kaiser and then
what it's like to have to lose world war
one and actually like lose
this the stain and then the rise within
everybody knows that story the beer hall
push and all that this one i like
and the reason i like kurt shaw is
obviously number one it's english which
is actually hard right like in order to
write that story
who can do both the primary source
material and then translate it
for people like us but he tells the
dynamic story of hitler
so well um in this second volume just
like the the level of detail and you've
you've talked about this lex like
what was it like inside that room inside
with chamberlain like
what was it like in terms of who was
this like magnetic
madman who did convince the smartest
people in the world at the time
and you know up until like 1940 the
soviet gamble
like was a trump it took tremendous
risks
but like highly calculated thinking no
no i'm not going to pay for this one i'm
not going to pay for this one
and it put himself he had a remarkable
ability not just to put himself in the
minds of the german people
but in terms of his adversaries like
with when he was across from mussolini
cow kill he's like how exactly did
mussolini the guy who created fascism
becomes like
second fiddle to hitler i think it's an
amazing bio
and yeah like ian kershaw along with
richard evans two of my favorite authors
on the third reich no question
you